first thing i would want to do is i
would really like to kind of talk about
some of my games in french and then
later on in
philadelphia and a little bit of
openings
so i'm gonna go ahead and show you one
of my
most favorite games in
french which obviously i won
this one is really great in particular
because it was i i remember this was a
um not a super high stake event because
i
i
kept playing those like normal events
and like world championship youth junior
and
it was always so
draining because by the time you
start to have fun in the tournament
you're like oh geez now i gotta actually
win and now i have to i'm fighting for
the gold and you know it starts to get
too real
or that you're fighting for a norm or
something so you have to be very
careful because well
if you lose it you lose the norm you
lose the gold you lose the whole thing
which happened so many times to me
so this one was a fun one because i
wasn't really fighting for anything
that severe
um
i will yeah i will go ahead and show you
a few other ideas few other lines that
happen to me over the next few weeks but
for now let's talk about this one
so
this is the most common lines there this
is the most common lines in vinover
there are so many other things black and
do
this is one of them this is one of them
black and try to give this guy a plaque
and try to external shortcast though
those are the two most common black and
try to do something super fun like this
and
quote unquote i
i remembered this was my god almost
eight years ago
uh in this specific game
um it happened to me in denmark 2014
and it was quite fun because i had
specifically kind of prepared for this
opponent who i saw played this coin a5
if you see any of my videos or read my
book i say that a lot
because if i know who i'm playing i'm
gonna prepare
for the opponents
and
hopefully
show them who's the boss
which is usually my cat right now
but so queen a5 the idea is simple they
want to eat my pawn so i gotta defend it
now
this is this really fun slash awkward
queen a4 which kind of prevents my coin
from moving because if i move it i lose
it if i play like bishop d3 they can do
this like c4
you do you don't really want to take it
because you get your paws tripled
but that's not necessarily true you can
easily actually take it
and after that it's quite fun because my
opponent fell for this he went queenie
for check
let me ask you
what to move what do you think is a good
idea to do
um
right
no children
i am under check
so there are few things that you have to
consider here
you can stop the check with a bishop
well either bishops you can stop the
check with the knight or with the queen
so you have four possible options all of
them seem kind of logical kind of good
only one of them saves this pawn but
even if you save that pawn we could lose
this pawn
so
decisions decisions
let me tell you a little
little thing that i've noticed with
chess players and non-jazz players it's
quite interesting chess players
professional chess players or people
who've been doing just for a long time
are usually
better at decision making in real life
which is not always true
but usually
a more decisive more like cultural
freaks a little here and there but
um
again i'm
generalizing but because you're in chess
you have to make decisions every move
you have to decide between so many other
options every move and yes you could
choose wrong
however you still have to make that
choice
and non-chess players
they don't really go through that they
don't have to
make choices like
um and then you know predict that future
yeah of course you make choice to go
grocery you drive this way blah blah but
with chess you actually have to take
someone else's ideas into account to
want to block them or let them make
mistakes like now
so i went queenie too and the idea was
that i'm trying to kind of take on my
opponent's queen i want to see what
you're gonna do are you gonna exchange
it because if you do i mean that's kind
of cool i'll have that extra pawn you
know yes it's a little uncomfortable but
i have two bishops your bishop is kind
of sucky i'm this is uh i still have to
like trying to c4 it's still a long game
but i have an extra pawn and i have two
bishops and i'm pretty happy about this
however if you fall for this trap
as my opponent actually did then he was
1900 something uh for freedev as well
now
we get this really amazing coin trap
that was a real game over the board
classic everything and i remember
the guy just looked up
he just looked down he just looked up
again and just stopped the clock
shopkins it's very beautiful short and
sweet i love it
so
what i'm trying to say is yes
this was an opening trap which he
completely fell for but i only did it
and i only played this take because i
knew the opening so you got to know your
openings
that's one big lesson
the other big thing is
you can kind of go on bractor not just
for your friends about how great chess
players are at decision making because
if you're training
all right so
um there are of course there are other
options too you know opponents can
easily play 97
and this is completely fine you get your
knight is pretty good here
there is a lot
to it of course because i'm trying to do
a little cheap trick
but you know your position is completely
fine
and i'm not going to get too into this
i'm just gonna like show you maybe five
more moves on how my game went of course
instead of g6 king f8 is also possible
king effect is very very common in
italian uh in french not in italian
um
but yeah so i can't try to um
eat some ponds which was probably not
the best idea in the hindsight
probably just getting this fish about
but
you know me i'm always hungry for
material
too
now i'm pretty good because this bishop
was a little problematic their knight is
really good and they just fixed my
king's problem they took away my
bishop's problem everything is
rainbows and unicorns now
a little bit more of rainbows and
unicorns
okay i may have messed up a bit here
whoops
this would have been better rainbows and
unicorns
anyways this is kind of getting um away
from the opening and my point is to show
you a little bit of opening a little bit
of what's possible
and
what i experienced so
queen a5 taking after queen a4 taking is
totally possible so
of course it's up to you you don't have
to take it there there's this there's
this i'm sure there are a bunch of
grandmaster games that you can follow
but dc5 has that little sweetness of uh
i just ate the pawn come get it
so that's what i choose
uh let's talk about
knight e7
again
queen c7 is completely possible as well
and if you try to go queen geforce 97 it
does transpose
but for argument's sake let's stay with
97 first
okay so
uh as
a
loyal puniture queen g4 is what you want
to go for again there are other lines
it's french you can do h4 you can do a4
you can i'm probably sure you can get
your knight out and still be fine with
this i'm not suffering bishop g5 is kind
of winking at me i'm not 100 sure about
that but here you'll be fine and it's in
the opening as long as you have a plan
on how to get your pieces out you'll be
fine okay so queen g4 the idea is
well first things first i want to eat
your pawn so you have
three
clear-ish ideas
queen c7 is a huge main line castling is
another huge main line and there's like
some fun stuff at kingf82
so we you want to make sure you know
them quite well let's start with
something weird what if knight f5 knight
f5
what do you think we should do
they're trying to defend this part
to where
um yeah i like that bishop d3 thank you
chad thank you in person
the episode d3 are pretty good you
develop your bishop and you get to poke
tonight
my opponent castled granted this was
years ago and my opponent was
quite lower rated but still
logical moves
so
in this game i win knight f3 i i kind of
still stand by it i don't really see why
not yeah you can try and take but at the
same time this could be a little bit too
much
because you still wanna try and push
over here but you lost your good bishop
that was a very critical bishop
i wouldn't take that unless i have to
so
all right let's get the horsey running
see now i kind of have to
because if i bring my bishop back then
my bishop isn't really doing much here
and we don't want um
kind of dead weight on us so if you have
to come back here and later on find a
better diagonal for the bishop which is
kind of
really hard to do at that point because
this is the best diagonal the bishop can
be in so if you have to vacate this
diagonal it's better to just liquidate
the bishop
then what do we want to do we gotta
choose a score for the queen i'm not the
biggest fan of exchanging queens in this
situation so queen g3
and my opponents played a very logical
move she just moved away with her king
and
here
again there are multiple good ideas one
of them
is this because this is you you kind of
free up your bishop from here that's a
very good diagonal for your bishop to be
in
but
i um
yeah this was world youth championship
world universe
ah interesting
world view championship 2014 where was
it oh this was doorbot wolf i have very
bad memories from there
um
uh i almost won the event and then i
didn't
and
that was still hurts when i think about
it
anyways i did win this game so
you got to figure out where you want to
place your bishop i see a few first-time
chapters which is great
so where do you want to place this
bishop
i see someone mentioning here so let's
go for it i agree
you push the coin but that's fine
uh here actually what do you think is
the best move
i hadn't done a very
deep
branch analysis
in early 2014 i remember like later in
2014 was where i started to really get
deeper in it and early 2015 was when i
believe
i
read maggie's book
yeah king d2 would have been the best
one exactly
in french it's so weird when the pawn
structure is like this
king d2 just somehow works
and you know everything in my body is
like no king d2 but it works
because they can't really attack it
you know i keep thinking if there was a
knight here but there isn't if there was
a bishop here but there isn't so king
due to completely does work
so
cast i went for castle because i wasn't
mentally ready for king d2 commitments
but
alright so castle
they took
which
[Music]
feels really wrong
i'm gonna leave it up to you what do you
think we should do
one
not a bad idea but
think more feisty
i mean this this kind of looks fine this
kind of looks fine too bishop of six
a little hard to probably
um yeah
yeah because you will be threatening
checkmate so they have to stop it but
then you will bring this returning
checkmate and eating the queen
which i did not see in the game i admit
would have been too pretty too
unrealistic
but actually this would have made some
such a cute puzzle you know what
if i end up writing another book i'll
definitely include this
sorry
why not
but yeah bishop those things would be
pretty cool so is bishop e7 why don't i
do this
let's say they move the rope i can again
do the same thing
still threatening checkmates you go back
knight g5 well i guess if i just see
bishop 6 the first time around bishop b7
wouldn't truly be
that awesome
anyways i slightly chickened out ah
yeah i just protected the pond i've
always been such a big fan of plants
eating them keeping them
man
all right um so after k2 it's again i
still have good advantage but
i missed that bishop six idea opponents
went back with the queen
now i did it
i had one move delay man
and i did this too but imagine how much
better it could be if their queen was
actually here with the actual attacker
in the queen too
oh yeah
all right so opponents tried to save the
game
and i saved my knight first and i'm
threatening to make a new queen and
check me too at the same time oh this is
a pretty cool game where has it been
hiding
why to move you
have a good advantage but you need to
find
the move
what does that mean
why to move
where do you want to go thank you
gustavo
sorry
you mean e5
oh yep
queen e5 would be the one because you
would be giving check and the awesome
part is if they take you promote
and
that's it yep
so opponents play drug f6
and i simply continued by well let's eat
it and let's make a queen and
kaboom
i truly did like this game i had
completely forgotten about it to be
honest
ah
this was a good one
all right so this is of course if you
get the exact same position in your game
i'll be very impressed but
i wanted to talk about this knight to 5
idea so here it is 95 idea
you still can get bishop d3 you'll bring
more pressure on this light
to be fair opponents best move would be
to do something along the lines of h4 uh
h5 and maybe try and exchange queens or
trying to take here and try and keep the
knight here but my opponents um i don't
think she had that great of an
understanding
from french and she just kind of castled
and then pushed made my decision for me
by playing c4 because in these type of
pawn structure when you play c4 you are
killing my bishop so i'm not going to
bring it back i'm going to liquidate it
so
all right let's go back a bit okay i
like queen g4 let's talk
take
so take was a little bit um
new for me because
i really really wanted to avoid these
queen g7s and i'll i'll tell you why my
reasoning is that
in the queen c7 idea
i'm very comfortable with bishop d3
nega's recommendation in his book
uh it kind of always tripped people off
didn't really matter what was their
writing they always kind of just got a
little hmm
because the main line is take or a cup's
here you take this they take this then
you get this guy out and then they take
this
and then there's like a weird h4 h5
where you can bring a queen bag
thank you thank you i forgot that with
one of my games too oh thank you
but yes
there is a fun f4 and then you gotta
bring this queen back and then you're
gonna somehow miraculously set up shop
for long castle and there's like
20-something theory that you're gonna
remember and you know what the opponent
knows it and everybody knows it and all
you have to do is remember it and ha
i just wanted to
um
not lose my mind
for french
so i really enjoyed this not queen g7
because everybody does it
so i like this bishop d3 idea
and for bishop d3 is pretty cool because
uh first of all not many people do it so
they don't really know how to play it
even if they know how to play it
it's very comfortable
and
i will get to it
in a moment
so when they take i could have taken on
g7 what if i take on g7 i don't really
get my bishop d3 anymore so i really
wanted to get my bishop d2 so i want
bishop d3
if you want queen g7 completely doable
if i want to play queen c7 boom
transpose
if opponent plays queen a5 as my
opponent did now
then i actually had to figure out what
to do
no more theory knowledge uh in the game
i went 92 which is fine but after castle
you get bishop g5 this is still fine but
you can also consider some stuff like
this so i'm gonna leave it up to you
knight t2 i had a pleasant position with
it and i was playing um almost the 2200
to figure it and
um he knew what he was doing but i had a
very comfortable game
okay i take it back i miss my pawn
now
what to move what do we do
um
h5
yeah
h5 would be pretty good because their
king is their weakness so we have to
kind of work with that weakness
yep
now you continue attacking you could
also just take this first
so
that would have been much more pleasant
i think i'll actually be much more
comfortable too why did i do that
i think i was just in a mood
yeah because taking of course is
checkmates they're not going to take it
server f6
i think this is also fine
getting a little harder though
yeah probably i made a mistake here
well
this is five but
if the center is really strong actually
not
yeah
it is it's kind of weird i keep thinking
castle but then they take this and ah
yeah i don't really want this rocket
suit rook takes h6 probably would have
been a little bit
uh more subtle because if work f6 now i
can just kind of pile up on this guy now
yeah this would have been a bit better
just a bit
but it's really hard to make these type
of decisions over the board you this
type of tactics is the ones that you
can't see the end and you're giving up
so much and you just have like two three
pieces going at the king and you just
don't know if those material is enough
so it's really hard to give up that much
anyways this game went well i ended up
winning it
let's move on
i want to show you uh the main lines and
i don't want us to run out of time
so queen c7
bishop d3
oh
let's see
uh there's this kind of a little bit of
annoying c4 line which i i'm gonna skip
for right now let's talk about what if
take
so if they take then what do you think
we should do
they want to eat here and give you a
check so you gotta stop that
92 yep good job your bishop is already
out you get your knife out too
no scary queen c3s so let's say first of
all what if they take
this for example
what can we do
why
well
you have a better way of doing that
even better
yeah
just eat that attack the queen
if the queen does move away boom
queen trap
what
yeah yeah it's kind of why we have this
special mask
protecting every square yep
clean trap yeah okay
yep
quite cool huh so it's not you know it's
not a dead end black can still do this
h5 and then you're gonna move this first
and then they can go the other way and
that's fine
however
white is still quite comfortable as well
i knew some points you can get out of
here
[Music]
right now
a lot of people missed that job
that is also true
so queen take c5 is a no go for i mean
it's fine but not the best one for black
so
lots of players played this against me
which i don't know why it doesn't really
attack anything i just eat it
so yay i have a great center this guy's
a little trouble i got the bishop out no
c4 so i'm happy with this if you cast
the well
welcome to my bishop
um a lot of players like tried h5 and
stuff with me and
then i can simply ah
take here
and if work g8 i can just move away and
this is just really really comfortable
even if point six comfortable
okay maybe not queen of six too
comfortable because i can't really do i
mean this is also fine but getting a
little scary so let's just let's just be
less scary go point h6 so they can't do
that if they do that i'll get a fun
bishop b5 out of it
yay
discovery attacks
all right
so
i think today is just queen eating day
for me
okay so let me go back back back so
knight c6 is also kind of a no-go
now um after they so let's say they
actually do the good idea they take it
what do we do now because they just ate
one pawn two upon so we gotta have
something up our sleeve
it's still
now let's
take h7
yep
now let's say they take now what
this is actually quite
tricky because
there are
two
kind of good moves that are kind of
similar but one of them is better
that's kind of what i felt for two no
actually
um
i believe the problem with bishop before
is after coin f6 that schwarz g2
actually works
because
i try like bishop g3 but then you
completely opponent made a mistake but
you completely lose control of the
center
and however if you play h4 first
if they end up taking it then you get
bishop g5
so you didn't really push upon his queen
away to give them e5 so you still kind
of trap the rook a bit
but you're not doing it at the expense
of
giving up center
so
the first time i actually played this in
a um
this line in a real game in like an over
the board game this is the mistake i
made
i actually went for
bishop of four first
and after queen f6 h4 take bishop g3
and my opponent he was an iem and he was
2400 but he still made a mistake because
he didn't know this opening and queen f3
looks looked more comfortable to him
and of course
wait
nope
did he do that
yes
no actually sorry he went knight c6 that
makes more sense was queen of three i
was alone
quinn f3 i could have just kept pushing
this guy and so or giving this check
stopping e5 okay
so he made a mistake but not that severe
he went knight c6
and he's still kind of pushing for e5 i
long castle he did e5 and it's already
getting scary right the center is really
um
unhappy for me i took this he continued
developing he could have easily just did
this
or even this
comfortably but he went for bishops
before and eventually i got a little bit
more
chances here and there and i ate a bunch
of stuff and he ate a bunch of stuff and
i had advantage he had advantage and
then we attended a draw the usual chess
games
so yeah he just repeated here
and
that was fine because you know kind of
funny if i play bishop d3 you can
checkmate me so
so like i had a choice to stop
this is not the professional but yeah
all right so
that's what you should know about bishop
before let's take a minute and talk
about h4
let's say they don't do the strict g2
the same pawn implies like a cool normal
bishop d7 i do what would you do now
but if you do that then this isn't this
scary a little
oh no
well i mean they're not going to take it
now but it's the the open file on your
king
the big thing is in this type of
positions because we have this pond it's
a past pawn right and we have a rook
supporting it that's kind of our big
star so we are kind of hoping to get rid
of a bunch of stuff and we can just keep
pushing this pawn
that's probably over simplification but
we would be happy if they want to
exchange queens because then we just get
to push this guy
whoa why did i make this [ __ ]
for example now oops not bad let's go h4
let's say what if they play like knight
d7 you can still go for this oh
that's the sound i like to hear
thank you for subscription even though
it's on twitch so one even though it's
not on twitch so if you do it on twitch
we'll be even more happy
all right let me go back to where we
were
yeah there's a before pretty cool
because if you go back trying to try and
exchange queens i'll be very happy about
it i'll just keep
being happy about it if you go queen of
six that's fine i'll kind of question
you do you want to go back or do you
want to go strange queens
and when they do which is again what we
do wants now we have these two bishops
they have this really cool pond that if
we can help promote that'll be awesome
the only downside that i see is um
well lack of center so you gotta be
careful about that
um
in this game i was playing another i am
oh this is like what seven years ago
it wasn't casara masters yeah so i've
been playing this specific line for over
a year now and i was very comfortable
with it but i still kind of wanted to um
i don't think i've ever actually had
this end game happen to me before that
this specific idea with the knight on d7
requirement [ __ ] but anyways i knew
that's i have to try and push this guy
so i tried to castle first and then try
and get this guy to roll but my
opponents got really good center
again
i'm really hoping to push this guy
but it started to get a little scary
because
he kept attacking my bishops
and i could have tried to save it but
then this bishop felt like he wasn't
really doing anything up there so i i
decided that it's okay if i
um kind of let the bishop go away
and so that's kind of what my opponents
went for soon after
okay got rid of that
and now yeah baby yeah thank you thanks
for the subscription
nice
all right
yeah
so
pond has a pretty goo goody goody center
i got a really nice pass pond they're
attacking my king currently they're
attacking my knight so
it's basically raining bananas
one of the ideas is take
let me ask you how many of you would
actually do this give up the knight for
two potentially three pawns
good
i didn't have the heart
okay i have a few eye woods
but it's crazy right you don't really
want you shouldn't really have to give
up your
um
material this much if
in endgame it's scary
so i didn't go for it and i kind of took
the chicken root crouch
and i just decided to defend this guy
and
i'm trying i was trying to find a way to
push these pawns
and
as you can see it can start to get a
little ugly which will be four and i
would have probably invested
i got lucky here exchanging these
defending this guy first because if i
can start pushing this
that's my main plan that's my main game
and if i also can get this light here
that'll be perfect
okay first little push
then try to bring in knight a little
more push bringing knights
going through here he just gave up the
rook
well i guess you have exchange
i'm still trying to push but i don't
want to end up losing my pawns
so changing direction
another beautiful check another push
another push
another push and he resigned
that's such a pretty
pretty answer
but this game could have easily went the
other direction because my opponent
could have very very easily
busted me
back here
a little before that problem there we go
bishop a4 keep the strong center start
attacking on my weakness before i get to
push the cars
what was his losing move he started to
lose control when he didn't play bishop
before and after d4 he kind of gave me
uh easier time trying to get the knight
out trying to defend this pawn
yeah like that
1994 was a big problem because my bishop
could be more
um
sorry their knights could be
their knights could be more useful for
them
and they didn't really use it
d4 followed by knight c4 really kind of
killed their game so
i guess they could have tried king g5
first knight f2 then bishop c6 trying to
stop this
but this is still very uncomfortable
because as soon as i gets like knight
h3o like this 3 is a weird square
maybe not d3
oh no
whoops
yeah their center is really really
strong i have to be very careful with
this
so
they made multiple bad moves but started
with
d4 okay
let's see i can probably squeeze in
one more
yeah let me see what if rookie shade
first so what do we do now
this was classical yeah this was in
qatar masters
can't remember which round though
game upon my back
i kept chasing that queen
and they finally gave him which is
not a good idea because now
look at these bishops
and then look at this pawn
just feels like a dream come true
beautiful push
yeah i ate a little ate a little more
trying to promote
boom oh i thought you would take well
actually if you took the g7
another boom beautiful
and this position is already
really better i'm very hesitant to use
the word winning but it's just really
really better because
well how do you plan to get your pieces
off
yep exactly
exactly
your pieces are stuck really really
stuck
all i have to do is find a happy way of
eating him
and i'm trying to be mean so i'm trying
to
not let you play this
freeing move
so all i'm doing is slowly slowly
not letting you
and eating more pieces hitting a little
bit more and stopping your promotion and
my opponent resigned here
okay
i'm gonna
go
a lot back
and
talk about this bishop d3 a little bit
more so bishop d3 really really good the
only thing that's always going to bother
me was the c4 because after c4 i'm going
to come back and then i get going 5 and
i can't really eat here and my bishop is
not in a happy place so
something to just kind of um be very
aware of
all right so
um i have actually a few games here
that kept it kept ending in draws
um
let me show you another line in the time
that we have left
we king of it
because castle is a very long one so
let's talk about king effect
what do we do
that's completely fine there are
multiple moves that are okay here one of
them is h4 i'm sure wizard g5 is fine
too
and i actually have tried h4 before and
it was always so weird because like
muhammad supposed to attack that king
so
um
it was always always very uncomfortable
and opponents got this bishop basics and
their tagging left and right and
really hard so
i this was actually one of the cool
games but i'm going to go back and show
you what i believe [ __ ] said on this
book it would have been much better if i
actually had the book here and i would
just show it every time i said it
but
i
might have um
made a small mistake there alright so
let's see
um
my opponent
after king f8
i'm still fine with h4 but i would um
advise on cautious
queen d1 is
recommended
i know you're all gonna give me you what
just happened look
but it's quite interesting because um
after queen d1
king got it oh well king can move pawn
can move the queen can come there's so
many ideas but the main idea is my
queen's work on g4 is done so i'm going
to get away from the rest of the pieces
so when my queen is no longer in front
of my pieces i can kind of push them
again
so
i went for bishop d2
upon probably taking is also an
interesting choice but opponents kind of
went for queen a4
queen b1
again this is so weird
because this queen just like going up
down left right what am i doing with
that queen but this is all theory
don't ask me who came up with it
actually i know who came up with it but
don't ask me how they came up with it
um
the idea is i'm blah i'm kind of uh
knowing your pawns
is the biggest idea ever
and yeah
and opponent can potentially try and
maybe like do a b6 but then bye bye
queen
slowly and slowly
um i guess opponents can potentially try
and maybe get some pieces rolling but
then again i still have this bishop b5 i
might have some h4 ideas
there's a lot of ideas like that
so
queen b1
and my opponents in this specific game
went for c4
which was really annoying because i was
really hoping to get this bishop
somewhere good
and so i have to find a better well i
now have to find a new idea for the
bishop i went for h4
and continued
to get my king side activated and the
opponent just kind of walked away with
the king which was kind of a
unhappy thought because i was really
hoping to attack that kingside
um like let's say if they play king g8s
now i can potentially try to get the
rook somewhere around here maybe start
with g4
h5 i have a lot of ideas like that so
but upon just one king e8
work my heart a bit
and i want queen d1
to be fair probably king f1 is a little
bit better
um
but i just really i i thought that my
queen's job here is done because was
attacking the pawn
i was attacking bishop b5 as well and
the position has changed my bishop can
no longer get out here this is a very
close center so i have the luxury of
moving the queen again
so
opponent played bishop d5 bishop d7 i
won bishop h5 attacking this guy
and continued my attack i think in
hindsight i might have
still king f1 might have been a bit
better
but
i was just really into kicking this
night away
trying to find a way to peacefully play
g4
and the position is still good but
alright question for the people
opponent f6 what do we do they seem to
be wanting to run away with their king
if we have two bishop the center is
super close what do we do do we take
this do we take this do we just let it
be what do we do
i mean you can but
they they're they're threatening to eat
this pump so okay
so
now what
this is french so it can't get a little
bananas
hey
[Music]
it's possible but there's a really good
move here that i missed and i want to
see if you guys
and gals can find it
that's good but the child can see it
so after rookie five pawn takes bishop
um king of one is fine but bishop [ __ ]
six is kind of the spicy way
afterward moves you can bring up the
knight you can attack here and this is
kind of you are very much suffocating
the opponent they can't really come up
with any good moves they have moves they
can defend it but
they don't really have a good idea all
the ideas are mine
i can get this guy up i can get this
this one rolling i can even go up here
continue like this so
yeah i didn't play rook takes f5 because
it just felt sorry so
surreal to me
i think that's the right
word uh i went for g4 and i decided to
give this up and i went for this banana
stuff
my idea was if they take i get bishop g5
i'm attacking here i'm talking there if
they get there i go up there
crazy
and my opponents also didn't accept this
sacrifice he went to king f7
i got a good bishop out of it
trying to drown with the king trying to
eat more pieces more material and my
position was really good but it was
quite um
it was not as easy to convert as i
thought because opponent started to
immediately like e5 and get centered
well he'll get now
yeah
and it was really um
hard to
actually i don't know why i didn't win
this
oh now i know why i didn't win this here
i made the mistake i should have tried
to simplify the position
but for some
unknown god awful reason i didn't i
didn't take my own advice when you have
extra material simplify i took with the
d-pawn and upon it took over here and
then they got d4 and i'm still better
but it is a little um i'm giving them
too much room for them for opponent to
slip away and
i finalized this
beautiful
knot masterpiece with my d4
and unfortunately opponents started to
really slip away and now i'm the one in
a bit of trouble because these two pawns
are really scary
and yes i was lucky enough to well not
lucky enough but i found the good ideas
and
stop this madness
but
i could have easily avoided all these
madness maybe i didn't draw here but i
could have easily avoided this madness
if i had just go back a bit more a bit
more chosen to keep these pawns steady
and just take with the mission
get your little bonus night if they do
take now even if they take here that's
okay because i immediately gets
opportunities for simplification and
then i have to connect with past pawns
and if they do change the rooks great
if they don't change the rooks well
that's
also kind of cool because they don't get
d4 anymore
shortly after if they say if they don't
exchange drugs i can immediately put
this knife on d4 boom stop that slide
push this way
so
yeah
so for now you guys and gals saw a few
of
my masterpieces a few of my not so
masterpieces
and we will continue again with maggie's
recommendation for french which you can
also find in his book
i think he only has one book series so
it should be easy to find um
so we'll continue on that
again not next week because i'm gonna be
in turkey but the week after that